we've secured the airport enabling
flights to resume
not just military flights but civilian
charters and other from other countries
and the ngos taking out
civilians and vulnerable afghan
vulnerable afghanis
and now we have almost 6 000 troops on
the ground including the 82nd airborne
providing runway security
the army 10th mountain division standing
guard around the airport
and the 24th marine expeditionary unit
assisting the civilian departure
this is one of the largest most
difficult airlifts in history
and the only country in the world
capable of projecting this much power
on the far side of the world with this
degree of precision is the united states
of america
we've already evacuated more than 18 000
people since july and approximately 13
000
since our military lift began
on august the 14th thousands more have
been evacuated on private charter
flights facilitated by the u.s
government
these numbers include american citizens
and permanent residents as well as their
families
it includes siv applicants and their
families
those afghans who have worked alongside
us
served alongside of us
gone into combat with us and provided
invaluable assistance to us such as
translators and interpreters
the united states stands by its
commitment that we've made to these
people and includes other vulnerable
afghans such as women leaders and
journalists
in fact working in close coordination
with the management of the new york
times the washington post and wall
street journal
we have successfully evacuated all 204
of their employees in afghanistan on u.s
military aircraft earlier this week
we've established the flow of flights
and we've increased the number of people
we're moving out of the country
we paused flights in kabul a few hours
this morning
to make sure we could process the
arriving evacuees at the transit points
but our commander on kabul has already
given the order for outbound flights to
resume
even with the pause
we've moved out 5
700 evacuees yesterday
and we're working on a variety
to verify that number of the americans
are still in country as we work on this
because we're not don't have the exact
number of people who are
americans are there and those who may
have come home to the united states
we're not we want to get a strong number
as to exactly how many people are there
how many american citizens and where
they are just yesterday
among the many americans we evacuated
there were 169 americans who over the we
got over the wall into the airport using
military assets we're also facilitating
flights for our allies and our partners
and working in close operational
coordination with nato
on this evacuation
for example
we provided overwatch for the french
convoy bringing hundreds of their people
from the french embassy
to the airport
these operations are
going to continue over the coming days
before we complete our drawdown
we're going to do everything everything
that we can to provide safe evacuation
for our afghan allies
partners and afghans who who
who
might be targeted if because of their
association with the united states
but let me be clear
any american who wants to come home
we will get you home
but make no mistake this evacuation
mission is dangerous
it involves risks to our armed forces
and it's being conducted under difficult
circumstances
i cannot promise what the final outcome
will be
or what it will be that it will be
without risk of loss
but as commander-in-chief
i can assure you that i will mobilize
every resource necessary
and as an american i offer my gratitude
to the brave men and women
of the u.s armed forces who are carrying
out this mission
they're incredible
as we continue to work the logistics of
evacuation we're in constant contact
with the taliban working to ensure
civilians have safe passage to the
airport
we're particularly focused on our
engagements on making sure every
american
who wants to leave can get to the
airport
where we have been seeing challenges
with americans for for americans we have
thus far been able to resolve them
we've been able we've made look and we
we've made clear to the taliban that any
attack
any attack on our forces or disruption
of our operations at the airport will be
met with swift and forceful response
we're also keeping a close watch on any
potential terrorist threat
at or around the airport including from
the isis affiliates in afghanistan who
were released from prison when the
prisons were emptied
and because they are by the way and make
everybody understand
that the the isis in afghanistan are
this have been the sworn enemy of the
taliban
i've said all along
we're going to retain a laser focus on
our counter-terrorism mission
working in close coordination with our
allies and our partners
and all those who have an interest in
ensuring stability in the region
secretary blinken is with me today met
this morning with our nato allies in
consultation about the way forward
so that afghanistan cannot be used as a
in the future as a terrorist base of
attack to attack the united states or
our allies
for 20 years afghanistan has been a
joint effort with our nato allies
we went in together
and we're leaving together
and now we're working together to bring
our people and our afghan partners to
safety
in the past few days
i've also spoken directly with the
british prime minister mr johnson
chancellor merkel of germany
and president macron of france
we all agreed
that we should convene and we will
convene the g7 meeting next week
a group of the world's leading
democracies so that together we can
coordinate our mutual approach our
united approach on afghanistan and
moving forward
we are united with our closest partners
to execute the mission at hand
we've also discussed the need to work
with the international community to
provide humanitarian assistance such as
food aid and medical care for refugees
who have crossed into neighboring
countries to escape the taliban
and to bring international pressure on
the taliban with respect
to the treatment of afghan afghan people
overall but including afghan
particularly women and girls
the past week has been heartbreaking
we've seen gut-wrenching images of
panicked people
acting out of sheer desperation
you know it's completely understandable
they're frightened
they're sad
uncertain what happens next
i don't think anyone i don't think any
one of us can see these pictures and not
feel that pain
on a human level
now we have a mission a mission to
complete in afghanistan
it's an incredibly difficult and
dangerous operation for our military
we have almost 6 000
of america's finest fighting men and
women at the kabul airport
and we're putting their lives on the
line and they're doing it in a dangerous
place
to save other americans our afghan
allies and citizens of our our li our
allies who went in with us
you know i i talk
i talk to our commanders on the ground
there every single day
as i just did a few hours an hour so ago
and i made it clear to them
that we'll get them whatever they need
to do the job
they're performing to the highest
standard under extraordinarily difficult
and dynamic circumstances
our nato allies
are strongly standing with us
their troops keeping century alongside
ours in kabul
as is the case
whenever i deploy our troops into harm's
way
i take that responsibility seriously
i carry that burden every day
just as i did when i was vice president
my son was deployed to iraq for a year
there'll be plenty of time to criticize
and second guess when this operation is
over
but now
now
i'm focused on getting this job done
i would ask every american
to join me in praying for the women and
men risking their lives on the ground in
the service of our nation
as events evolve
over the coming days
my team and i will continue to share the
information and update the american
people on exactly where things are
we'll use every resource necessary to
carry out the mission at hand
and bring the safety american citizens
and our afghan allies
this is our focus now
and when this is finished
we will complete our military withdrawal
and finally bring to an end
20 years of american military action in
afghanistan
thank you may god bless you our troops
our diplomats and all those serving in
harm's way
and now i'll take questions ap
zeke miller
afghanistan but you also promised
not to to help to bring out those who
helped america in its war effort we've
seen these heart-wrenching images at the
kabul airport of people trying to get
there say nothing of the people who
can't get to that airport you made the
commitment to get american troops out to
get them get american citizens out will
you make the same commitment to those
who assisted in the american war effort
over the last 20 years number one
and then on number two what is your
message to the america's partners around
the world who have criticized not the
withdrawal but the conduct of that
withdrawal and made it made them
question america's credibility on the
world stage i have seen no question of
our credibility from our allies around
the world
i've spoken with our nato allies we've
spoken with nato allies
the secretary of state our national
security advisers have been in contact
with his counterparts throughout the
world and our allies as has
the general or excuse me i keep calling
them in general but my secretary of
defense
the fact of the matter is i have not
seen that matter of fact the exact
opposite i've gotten the exact opposite
thing is we're acting with dispatch
we're acting committing to what we said
we would do look let's put this thing in
perspective here
what interest do we have in afghanistan
at this point with al-qaeda gone
we went to afghanistan for the express
purpose of getting rid of al-qaeda in
afghanistan as well as as well as
getting osama bin laden and we did
imagine just imagine if
that attack if bin laden had decided
with al-qaeda to launch an attack from
yemen
would we ever gone to afghanistan would
there ever be any reason we'd be in
afghanistan
controlled by the taliban
what is the national interest in the
united states in that circumstance
we went and did the mission you've known
my position for a long long time
it's time to end this war
the estimates of the cost of this war
over the last 20 years range from a
minimum one trillion dollars
to a think tank at one of the
universities saying 2 trillion that's
somewhere between 150 million dollars a
day and 300 million dollars a day
the threat from terrorism has
metastasized
there's a greater danger from isis and
and and and al qaeda and all these
affiliates and other countries by far
than there is from afghanistan and we're
going to retain
an over the horizon capability that if
they were to come back to be able to
take them out
surgically move
so this is this is where we should be
this is about america leading the world
and all our allies have agreed with that
and by the way before i made this
decision
i was at the g7
as well as met with our
nato partners and i told them all every
one of them knew and agreed with the
decision i made to and end and jointly
end our involvement in afghanistan the
first part of your question was i can't
remember now
would you commit to the same commitment
would you make the same commitment to
bring out afghans who assisted in the
war efforts yes yes we're making the
same commitment there's no one more
important than bringing american
citizens out i acknowledge that but
they're equally important almost as all
those who those sivs we call them who in
fact helped us there were translators
they went in the battle with us they
were part of the operation
as well as we're also trying to get out
as many ngos
non-government organizations women's
organizations etc we're doing all we can
in the meantime
uh secretary blinken and i am going to
be working with our allies to see to it
that we can bring international pressure
on the taliban to be they're looking to
gain some legitimacy
they're going to have to figure out how
they're going to maintain that country
and there's going to be harsh conditions
where strong conditions we're going to
apply and will depend on whether they
get help based on whether or not how and
well they treat women and girls how they
treat their citizens so this is just
beginning in that score
they passed the 31st to make that happen
to bring all the americans out to bring
those sivs out i think we can get it
done by then but we're going to make
that judgment as we go now justin sink a
bloomberg
thank you mr president um
you just said that you would keep a
laser focus on counter-terrorism efforts
and you don't see as great of a threat
of terrorism from afghanistan as other
parts of the world but if you and your
administration so badly misassessed how
quickly the taliban would sweep through
afghanistan and we no longer have an
embassy there from which to run
intelligence operations how can you at
all be confident of your assessment of
the risk of terrorism
and the ability of the us to conduct
over the horizon missions to keep it in
check can you tell americans that
they're safe and will remain safe from
terror attacks in afghanistan
i think you're comparing apples and
oranges one question was whether or not
the afghan forces we trained up
would stay and fight
in their own civil war they had going on
no one
shouldn't say no one the consensus was
that it was highly unlikely that in 11
days they'd collapse and fall the leader
of afghanistan would flee the country
that's a very different question than
whether or not
there is the ability to observe whether
or not large groups of
terrorists begin to accumulate in a
particular area in afghanistan to plot
against the united states of america
that's why we retained an over the
horizon capability to go in and do
something about that if that occurs
if that occurs but in the meantime we
know what's happened around the world we
know what's happening in terms of what's
going on
in other countries where there is a
significant rise
of terrorist organizations in the middle
east in east africa and other places and
so
the bottom line is we have to do we're
dealing with those terrorist threats
from other parts of the world and failed
states without permanent military
without without permanent military
presence there we have to do the same in
afghanistan
sir just on that initial assessment we
we learned over the last 24 hours that
there was a descent cable from the state
department sure
saying that the taliban would come
faster through afghanistan can you say
why after that cable was issued the u.s
didn't do more to get americans all
kinds of cables all kinds of advice if
you notice
it ranged from
this
group saying that they didn't say it
fall when it would fall when it did fall
but saying that it would fall to others
saying it wouldn't happen for a long
time and they'd be able to sustain
themselves through the end of the year
i made the decision
the buck stops with me
i took the consensus opinion the
consensus opinion was that in fact it
would not occur if it occurred until
later in the year so it was my decision
now my i got my next is stephanie ramos
abc
thank you mr president two questions for
you the military has secured the airport
as you mentioned but will you sign off
on sending us troops into kabul to
evacuate americans who haven't been able
to get to the airport safely
we have no indication that they haven't
been able to get in kabul through the
airport we've made an agreement with the
with the taliban thus far they've
allowed them to go through it's in their
interest for them to go through
so we know of no circumstance where
american citizens are carrying an
american passport are trying to get
through to the airport but we will do
whatever needs to be done to see to it
they get to the airport and one more mr
president last month my colleague martha
raddatz interviewed abdul an interpreter
who was on the front lines with us
forces in afghanistan
overnight we received a photo of taliban
militants coming to the door
of his home literally hunting him down
thankfully he was able to escape but he
is obviously still in mortal danger
what would be your message to abdul his
wife and his three young daughters
we want you to be able to get to the
airport contact us we'll see whatever we
can do to get you there we've got to get
you out we are committed to deal with
you your wife and your child to get all
three of you out of afghanistan
that's the commitment
thank you sir meredith lee
of pbs newshour
you mentioned just now using every
resource available for evacuations why
haven't you ordered the military to
expand the security perimeter around the
kabul airport do you have any plans to
do so giving that will likely require
more u.s troops and are you considering
rescue operations to recover americans
and afghan allies stuck behind taliban
checkpoints
the last answer is yes to the last
question we're considering every op
every opportunity and every means by
which we could get
folks to the airport that's number one
number two the reason why we have not
gone out and started and set up a
perimeter
way outside the airport in kabul is that
it's likely to draw an awful lot of uh
unintended consequences in terms of
people who in fact
are not
part of the taliban we've been in
constant contact with the taliban
leadership
on the ground in
in kabul
as well as the taliban leadership at
tahoe and we've been coordinating what
we're doing that's why we were able for
example
how we got all of our embassy personnel
out how we got everyone out of the
embassy safely that was the distance
that's how we helped get the french out
and out of their embassy so
the question remains there will be
judgments made on the ground by the
military commanders at the moment
and that i cannot second guess each of
those judgments to be made but
the idea of
again let me let me get back to the
fundamental point
i made at the outset
when
the decision was made
by me
that and it was made some time ago and i
ran for president saying i wanted to get
us out of afghanistan
one of the things that um
is a reality is people now say
to me and to others and some many of you
say it on air
that
why did we have to
move because no americans are being
attacked
why did we withdraw those why do we
agree to withdraw 2500 troops no
americans are being attacked
as i said before
the reason they weren't being attacked
was part of an agreement that trump had
made
a year earlier
we will leave by may 1st he said as long
as there's no attack on americans in
that year period
number one number two the taliban was
taking large swaths of the countryside
north and south
none of the major
areas none of the major uh uh points of
uh the the capitals of each of these
provinces but they were all over the all
over the country
and the idea
that if i had said on
may the second or third
we are not leaving we are staying
does anybody truly believe
that i would not have had to put in
significantly more american forces
send your sons your daughters
like my son was sent to iraq
to maybe die
and for what
for what
so the only rational thing to do in my
view
was to set up and pre-position american
forces
for the purpose of evacuation and the
aircraft to pre-position those ahead of
time
so that we would be able to begin the
process
of evacuation
of american citizens sivs and others who
helped us
the last point i'll make is this look um
if we had decided 15 years ago
to leave afghanistan
it would have been
really difficult
if we decided five years ago
if we started we continued the war for
another decade and tried to leave
there's no way in which
you'd be able to leave afghanistan
without there being some of what you're
seeing now
but what we've done so far
has been able to get a large number
of americans out all our personality
embassy out and so on and thank god so
far knock on wood
we're in a different position
scott
detrow scott
npr
thank you mr president i just want to
follow up on something you said a moment
ago you said that there's no
circumstances where american citizens
cannot get to the airport
that doesn't really square with the
images we're seeing around the airport
with the reporting on the ground from
our colleagues who are describing chaos
and violence are you saying
unequivocally that any american who
wants to get to the airport is getting
there and getting past the security
barrier and to the planes where they
want to go i thought the question was
how can they get through to the airport
outside the airport and the answer is
the best of our knowledge
the taliban checkpoints they are letting
through
people showing american passports now
that's a different question when they
get in the rush and crowd of all the
folks just outside the wall near the
airport that's why we had to i guess yet
was it yesterday the day before
we went over the wall
and brought in
how many
169 americans
so it is a process to try to figure out
how we
how we
deal with the mad rush
of
non-americans those who didn't help
those who are not on the priority list
just any afghan any afghan to be able to
get out of the country and so my guess
is that no matter what under what
circumstances we
anyone there's not a whole lot of
afghanis uh there's a whole lot of
afghanis that just as soon come to
america whether there are any
involvement with the united states in
the past at all rather than stay
under taliban rule or any and any rule
so what i was saying is that we have an
agreement
that they will let pass through
the checkpoints
that they the taliban control and put
americans through but given this given
the negotiations with the taliban the
scenes that we're saying can you just
fully explain why
the plan wasn't to go ahead with these
evacuations of both americans and allies
before the drawdowns began before bagram
was closed looking back several months
because whether it was now or several
months from now there seems to be a
broad consensus that the taliban would
make these gains and these would be
needed at some point
well yeah at at some point
but the point was that although we were
in contact with the taliban and doha for
this whole period of time
that some point wasn't expected to be
the total demise of the afghan national
force
which was 300 persons let's assume the
afghan national force
had continued to fight
and and they were surrounding kabul
be very different story
very different story
but the overwhelming consensus
was that they this was not they were not
going to collapse the afghan forces they
were not going to leave they were not
going to just abandon and then put down
their arms and take off
so that's what happened
thank you very very much
[Applause]
so president joe biden there speaking
live at the white house addressing the
issue of the evacuation of u.s citizens
and their allies from afghanistan for
the first time in a few days and
painting a picture there of a difficult
mission but one that was making progress
he did say any american who wants to
come home we will get you home and he
also said that the evacuation was
dangerous was being conducted under
difficult circumstances in fact at one
point he said it was one of the largest
most difficult airlifts in history but
he did say that he would mobilize every
resource necessary well let's bring in
our u.s correspondent mark stone who was
listening into that he's live in
washington for us now
so mark in the last week we've seen a
defiant president biden defending his
decision to pull out u.s troops and the
nature in which he did that did we get
anything different tonight
well we heard that message again uh a
defense of the policy to pull out of
afghanistan um but i think there was
more of an attempt tonight uh by him or
this afternoon by him
to i guess to to spin as positively he
as he can
the mission the the immediate mission
now around in and around the airport at
kabul and he was trying and remember
he's speaking to an american audience uh
first and foremost and he was trying to
to paint this picture saying that the
american military is the only the amer
america is the only country in the world
capable
of doing of doing an airlift like this
the biggest airlift perhaps in history
really sort of trying to g up uh the
attempt by the american military to do
what it's doing now but of course this
comes on the back of an american
decision this chaos has come as a
consequence of a decision that he made
um a number of other points uh that that
i thought were well one was quite quite
extraordinary he said that i have seen
no question of our credibility from
allies around the world in fact i have
got the opposite i mean that just
is just plain wrong i mean openly there
has been criticism uh in london in paris
in berlin
in brussels at nato
we have heard uh
deep unease with with the way in which
this operation has unfolded so i mean he
clearly wasn't watching of course he
wasn't he's got much more important
things to do immediately but he clearly
had not been briefed on the sentiment in
the house of commons that we heard
just yesterday
he was asked about this idea of you know
a very pointed question by bloomberg and
that
if america well we know that america got
the intelligence so wrong in the sense
that the taliban returned in just days
how can we be sure
that that afghanistan is no longer can
no longer be used as a safe haven for
terrorists and he seemed to suggest that
it was perfectly possible with with over
the horizon intelligence in other words
using assets in other countries to be
able to look in on a country that you'd
be able to to maintain or guarantee to
the american people that there could
never be a terrorist attack from
afghanistan
again it wasn't um particularly
convincing but then at the very end he
came back to this point about the
reasoning and i think he's just trying
to push this home as hard as he can the
reason
for leaving afghanistan he didn't want
to forever war he he believes that the
threat of al qaeda has been eliminated
and therefore what is the point in
staying uh in afghanistan well i can
tell you having spoken to to see uh
recently retired cia operatives uh here
uh and other military officials they
will tell you that the taliban and
al-qaeda are literally intermarried the
idea that you can say that al qaeda has
been defeated is not the view
of of many in the intelligence and
military community here so
a gap there between what the u.s
president is saying and what many behind
the scenes are saying a brief word on
the the choreography of it which i
thought was interesting behind clearly
all american stars and stripes in
previous news conferences we have seen
him uh with different flags military
colours behind him this was as it was
the other day an all-american
message and then he was flanked on his
right by the u.s vice president kamala
harris on his left uh by the secretary
of state uh
tony blinken and then just off camera uh
where um the uh
the secretary of defense uh and also the
national security adviser this was an
attempt to to show unity uh the the
administration together trying to fix
this i guess it was also an
attempt to show we're all in this
together this wasn't just his decision
he's got people around him who would
have been advising him